c'est la première fois que georges et
nathalie enfile un gilet jaune
la première fois qu'il se rende
manifester ainsi à paris pour se faire
entendre eux aussi entre retraite trop
maigre et emplois précaires
il n'y arrive plus et se reconnaissent
dans le mal de vivre exprimées dans la
rue
moi je travaille j'ai mon salaire la fin
du mois à la fin du mois j'ai plus rien
même pas la fin du mois avant la fin du
mois j'ai plus rien tu pourrais pas
mettre de côté c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible depuis chartres et les fans
moi je les ai même pas je sais pas s'il
ya tous deux voulaient manifester
paisiblement vers les champs elysées
mais impossible d'approcher bloqué par
5000 policiers
impassible face à toute tentative de les
amadouer
rapidement la situation dégénère les
policiers tirent des salves de gaz
lacrymogènes pour chasser les
manifestants et la tension monte d'un
cran une pluie de pavés s'abat sur les
policiers qui ripostent encore plus
durement
l'arc de triomphe et bientôt noyé dans
un nuage de fumée
jonathan venu bretagne est dégoûté par
l'attitude des policiers
mais regardez là c'est eux qui poussent
la faute ce qui pousse et ses larmes
les jeunes en ont marre ils on m'a
regardé comme on est traités [ __ ]
c'est normal ça incapables d'accéder aux
champs elysées les manifestants se sont
dispersés dans les avenues alentours qui
ont tout pris des allures de bataille
rangée
partout des barricades sont dressées et
les rues sont bientôt jonchée de pavés
de débris et de véhicules calcinés
les dommages sont considérables et ils
sont loin de n'être que matériels des
policiers en civil infiltrés parmi les
gilet jaune arrêtent des centaines de
manifestants
sans pour autant mettre un terme aux
violences qui redoublent d'ampleur et
s'étendent au reste la capitale
des affrontements mais suivi à distance
par le président maquereau à la sortie
du sommet du g20 il se dit ferme de
déterminer je respecterai toujours les
contestations
j'entendrai toujours les oppositions
mais je n'accepterai jamais la violence
pendant ce temps dans paris plongé dans
la nuit
les incendies se multiplient des
brasiers couleurs de ras-le-bol à
l'image de la grogne qui monte dans le
pays et qui s'annonce difficile à
étouffer
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
paris